get [__] ready for this all right
I've been doing this in sixth grade my
cousin Adrian showed me how to do it
because his cut his brother Billy showed
him I asked my science teacher Miss
Bentley what it means and she looked at
me and just went I don't know what that
is
ready before I ever smoked ever I can do
this so it's not like I'm burping smoke
up watch
did you see it Marty yes did you see it
yeah
how would you have started to do that
before because my cousin Adrian did it
and I go what did you just do how did
you just make smoke come out of your
mouth because at the time uh cigarette
bubble gum cigarettes were the coolest
thing in the world because you could
pretend you're smoking everyone I knew
smoked all the parents so it's like
that's cool how did you do it awesome
David Blanchard I had to give him two
dollars for him to show me how to do it
two dollars in the sixth grade or
seventh grade that was detrimental it's
a good investment though look at us oh
yeah
thank you